with three beat weave. It's a classic po
trick. We all learn it at some point
when we're picking up the prop. But very
important question. Once you get it
down, what comes next? And friend, I've
got you covered. I'm going to help you
out with a couple drills that'll give
you some more things that you can do
with your three beat weave and an
additional three tricks that you should
learn after you pick it up.
Drex here from Drex Factor PO sharing
with you the love of PO spinning and
flow arts to benefit your body and
brain. And in this video we're going to
talk about what to tackle next after you
get down your three beat weaves. But
before we dive in, I just want to give a
quick shout out to the friends of the
channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk, Fire
Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyoter,
Light Toys, and Ultraoy for helping to
make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these awesome companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
down in the description of this video.
And special thanks to the non-B business
friend of the channel, Becca Beckonin.
Thank you so much for supporting my
channel, my work, and my mission. All
right, three beat weaves. We all know
them. We all love them. And if you don't
already have it under your belt, I've
got a tutorial on how you can pick it up
inside of a half an hour that I'm going
to go ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
So, assuming that you've got that three
beat weave down, what exactly do you
learn how to do next? So, first and
foremost, I think that whenever you
learn a new PO trick, you ought to do a
couple different exercises to experiment
and see what presentations of that PO
trick you can get out. So, for example,
when you're playing around with a three
beat weave, I would say the first thing
to play around with is both volume as
well as levels. So when I say volume,
what I mean is explore and see where
exactly you can make the trick expand to
fill up a bigger space and also just how
little of space you can fill up as
you're performing it. You'll find
there's a lot of range here. And
specifically with a three beat weave,
what I'd recommend doing is starting off
by just reaching around big with one
hand at a time. You might just start off
by having your left hand go big on one
side and then having your right hand go
big on one
side and then alternating back and
forth. The left go big, the right go
big, the left go big, the right go big.
And then seeing if you can go big with
both hands at the same time like so. And
then of course seeing how small a space
you can keep your hands in and still
keep the trick
going. You can go back and forth between
these extremes. Go big, go big, go big,
go small, go small, go small, go big, go
big, go big, go small, go small, go
small, and see what range of motion you
get out of that. In addition, we can
also play around with levels with this
trick. So, for example, as I'm just
performing this three beat weave here at
about like the bottom of my chest, I can
take it up into the air and perform it
above my head. I can take it down and
perform it down towards the ground like
so. I can also play around with this
range of motion with my body at
different levels too. So rather than
just being at kind of a neutral level, I
can say lunge down and get a little bit
low, take the poi up high as I perform
the weave and take them down low as I'm
performing the weave. Or I can go all
the way down to kneeling on the ground.
Perform that weave up in the air.
Perform it as close to the ground as I
possibly can. And of course in each of
these spots, perform it at my normal
level about even with my shoulders or
down near my chest. All these things
work. And of course you can combine
together all of these things and say
play around with both your levels and
your volume. See what comes out of that.
Sometimes you can find some really,
really cool possibilities here. And more
than anything else, you'll be able to
find a lot of different performance
possibilities for a trick that you
already know how to do. Okay, so having
explored some range of motion with this
PO trick, then what about playing around
with some additional tricks? Well, the
most obvious thing that I can think of
when playing around with weaves is to
learn not just the forwards weave, but
also the reverse weave. And perhaps most
importantly, learn how to perform them
in such a way that you perform the
forwards weave going over to one side of
the stage and the reverse weave going
off to the other side of the stage. This
is something that we refer to as
performing a waist wrap. It takes your
weaves back and forth across your body.
Whenever you first learn your weave,
it's not that unusual to think of it as
just kind of pointing out towards your
audience. But the conventions around poi
performance as they are right now tend
to flatten everything uh with regard to
the perspective of the audience. So if
you perform the weave off to the side,
your audience is going to see more of
the path of the poi as it goes through
the air. Likewise, we can then take that
waist strap back and forth and create a
version of the weave that has a little
bit more dynamic presence for our
audience than say if we were just
performing this while facing straight at
them like so. And if you'd like to learn
how to do those reverse weaves so you
can get this waist wrap down, I did do a
tutorial that'll take you through five
specific steps in learning how to do the
reverse weave that I will go ahead and
link to down in the description as well
as up in the cards. And if you have your
waist straps down, then there is a very,
very minor tweak that you can do that
will really, really, really emphasize
those levels. And that is to turn them
into a sixbeat fountain. All this
involves is that as you're taking the
poi back and forth across your body
here, rather than going across a line
that's about even with your shoulders,
you bend that line down around past your
hips and then up and over your head,
turning it into a circle and meaning
that you're carrying the poi down and
around or up and over as you're going
back and forth between your forwards and
reverse weaves. If you've got your waist
straps down, this is actually a pretty
easy step to take. I did a tutorial on
this just recently that I will go ahead
and once again link to down in the
description as well as up in the cards.
And for the final trick that I'd
recommend you learn after your three
beat weaves, we're going to take a
little bit of a left turn. And we're
going to play around with something that
at first may not look a whole lot like a
weave, but actually has more in common
with weaves than you might think. This
is a 1.5, or as it's sometimes called,
the 1.5 beat weave. So 1.5 beat weaves
essentially take what would be a three
beat weave and whichever hand is coming
around on top suddenly pulls out of the
weave and instead performs a pendulum
rather than simply spinning the poi over
the other hand. This means that they
actually transition back and forth with
three beat weaves quite easily. You just
have to know when to take one hand out
to do the pendulum and when to bring it
back in to resume the three beat weave.
To get that 1.5 down, I want you to take
one hand and spin the poi down near your
hip, while the other hand is up above
your head and bring it back and forth in
a little pendulum like this. We're
looking for that moment when both of the
poi point out towards the same direction
away from you. We want to think that
we're going to drop both poi down on
that side of you in
three,
two, one reps. And then we switch which
side of our body these poi and hands
happen to be on. Whichever hand is
crossing over is the one that winds up
at your hip. So as I move over to my
right side, it's going to be my left
hand spinning the poi. And my right hand
is going to be up high doing the
pendulums. Once again, I'm going to
think three, two, one, and let both of
my hands go out to the side and come
back over to my left with my right hand
spinning the poi. Three, two, one. They
both go out.
Three. Two. One. They both go out. And
then we do two. One. They both go out.
Two. One. They both go out. And then
just one, one, one. If you want a more
detailed tutorial on this, well, you
already know the rigomearroll link down
in the description as well as up in the
cards. All right. So from here, if you
want to jump back into that threebeat
weave, we're looking for that moment
where the hand reaches around above and
switches into a pendulum. And we just
don't let it. We keep it down below. And
that means that the PO keeps on spinning
and we drop back into the three beat
weave. To get out of the three beat
weave, whichever hand is supposed to go
over the other one on a given side, you
want to reach it up high and take away
the momentum of the po so it just hangs
in a pendulum like so. So, we can go in
and then back out easily. I recommend
learning how to do this on both sides of
your body, going
out and dropping back in. Cool. What did
you think of my list of things to learn
after you get down a three beat weave?
Were there other things that were
obvious that I should have included in
here or other tricks that some of you
veterans out there learned after your
three beat weave and think are pretty
essential? Leave me a comment and let me
know. Be sure to like, comment, share,
and subscribe to help other people find
this video and of course to help my
channel grow. Hey friends, Drex from the
future here. And wouldn't you just know
it? After I shot this video, some uh
threads came together. And now, if you
are looking for some tips and help on
how to get down those weaves, waist
straps, and fountains. I'm going to be
teaching an entire live stream class
unit on these tricks up on Crowdcast. Uh
we'll over the course of four weeks be
covering not just how to perform all
these tricks, but also some of my best
performance tips on how to make them
look good. So if you want to join us, uh
you can sign up and get early bird
pricing before April 15th by following
the link down in the description of this
video. I will also put text for it up on
screen. So I can't wait to have you
there. And I hope that you're down to
come flow and grow with me.
This video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on Patreon. In
particular, I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now. Thank you. You all
rock. I could not do this without you.
And if you would like to get your name
in the credits or access to any of the
awesome rewards that I have available to
my supporters, you can go sign up for my
Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactor poi. Link down in
the description as well as up in the
cards. And more than anything else,
doing so helps me out in my mission to
bring po spinning and flow arts to the
whole wide world. So go check that out,
please. And thank you. And if you'd like
some other ideas for things that you can
learn after the three beat weave, I did
a video in my what comes next series
specifically on three beat weaves that
I'll go ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up on screen.
Thanks so much for watching. Make sure
to get out and flow yourselves today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon.
Take care now. Peace.